It was the first time ever that I just realised how totally and
utterly insignificant I was, and it's a beautiful thing to have a
moment in your life where you just are, to recognise that you
are smaller than a leaf in the wind.
This landscape is so vast and so huge and so dauntingly
threatening, but at the same time beautiful.
It's amazing. Yeah.
And then it was I got this is really out there.
This is, you know, nothing. And yeah, it was that moment
that, yeah, just changed. It actually probably changed my
life. Hello and welcome back to
Paragliding Atlas Podcast. I'm your host Aninder Singh, and
in case you have been wondering, why did I take such a long time
to get back to you? My reason for that is that life
has been absolutely magically fun in the past few weeks, or
months I would say. Airtime was coming and taken
fast, and I was exploring the world from above in places that
I'd always wished for. Long story short, a lot of
travels, more or less living the dream the way it is supposed to
be done. And yeah, screen time was not a
priority. However, with that being said, I
have missed being here. I have missed interacting with
you. But a massive thank you to all
of you guys who came up in person and said hello while my
travels were going on. And now for today, we have
someone who we can consider as one of the real Ogs of the
sport. I'm talking about none other
than the man himself, Robbie Whittle, who also is known by
the name Robert Whittle, which I just discovered today.
Robbie, welcome to the show. This is an honour beyond words.
Well, thank you very much for the invitation.
And I'm not really quite sure it's such an honour because it's
only me, but thank you very much for inviting me and I'm looking
forward to talking to you. Robbie the reason why I'm so,
and I'm pretty sure I'm not the only one, I think a lot of
members in the audience can also relate to this.
Having somebody come out and chase their dreams to the
fullest is an inspiration to watch and having someone do that
in the in the passion that you share yourself is very
relatable, I would say. So, I mean, this is a huge and
wide question, but usually when you look back at the way you
have managed to live life, what is one thing that you said that
you did right, which kept you on track in getting what you really
wanted? Right.
Well, yes, it's a, it is a, it's a question.
Is that one? That's a real question.
Well, if I if I think honestly and openly, then the real answer
is dedication. It's dedication to the cause.
And you know, if you look around you, all the people who are
successful in whatever they choose to be successful in, the
primary factor in their success is dedication.
For sure, you need to have a sort of love and a passion for
whatever it is that you're involved in, but you also need a
single minded kind of dedication.
And I would say that in my life with the different phases of my
life, the one sort of constant is that there has been
dedication towards something. So in the early years, then it
it was Hang Gliding, then that turned into paragliding, which
is still flying. That is it.
I was dedicated to free flight, shall we say.
Then it turned into business. And I was very dedicated in
business or to the business. I wasn't sorry when I say
dedicated to business. I was dedicated to my part of
the business, which was research and development.
Again, still involving flying. Because really if it, when I
look at myself, I'm dedicated to, to sport in a way, you know,
so flying's a sport. Kiting as I moved into, later
moved into kites and kite design.
It was dedication to the sport because I, I like to be active
and moving. But the overall factor is yes,
as I say, all all success seems to be underlined by dedication.
You know, Robbie, I, I resonate with that very well because
eventually, umm, you know, when I was growing up, I was chasing
field hockey pretty, pretty hard.
You know, I wanted to be in the Olympics, wanted to get on the
podium, chase the gold. And when you, when you have
emotions that strong in your daily routine, it's, it's not
that hard to become obsessed with your craft.
So how do you is there a way to define dedication versus
obsession? Or is it more or less the same
thing that we speak about, whether we just label it
differently depending upon the time?
These are great questions, honestly.
You know, dedication and obsession.
Let's say that dedication is the polite way of saying obsession.
And we like to use polite terms when we're talking about ourself
and when we're talking about others.
So we use the word the word dedication rather than
obsession. But, you know, I can definitely
say that I have an obsessive nature because I obsess about
these things. When once a feeling, for
instance, let's we'll just go to that feeling in the beginning,
when I first went free flying solo, flying myself on a hang
glider, the feeling was so amazing and yeah, so expansive
in the way that I felt a certain freedom that I'd never felt
before that I became ultimately so dedicated to it that it was
my obsession, you know, So yes, I'm very much obsessed.
But I think that there's nothing wrong with obsession or
dedication to that level where you're obsessed because so long
as it's in a positive nature, you know, you don't want to be
obsessed with things that are destructive to your nature and
to other people. But when they are, you know, the
more time I spent in the air, I probably believe they the better
it was for me because, you know, in a way it was a release or it
was a release and a connection. At the same time, you know,
you're you're releasing the constraints of society and the
world that we live in. And at the same time, you're
truly connecting with the elements, which is fulfilling,
which is refilling the part of what you're releasing.
Because, you know, I think it's quite easy to see that when we
live in a constructed society, which we do, it might not align
with the true self. And so therefore we need to find
these escapes. And for me, that escape was
flying. And yes, it became my obsession.
So in a in a very positive way. Yeah, I love the word positive.
The the original word positive in the end, because I think that
is very important to mention. The reason I'm saying that is I
had Russ Ogden on my show in the previous episode.
And after we stopped recording, Russ was very kind to stay with
me for a chat. And we, we ended up speaking
about you because I was, I was discussing my dreams with Russ.
And I was like, Russ, you know, Long story short, I want to have
my life full of flying. And, and he was like, what is
your inherent desire? What do you really want to make
out of it? And I was like, if I can go out
and fly every day, I'll feel that I have one at lice.
And he was like, yeah, but you don't want to lose the fun of it
or the joy of it or, you know, whatever it comes.
So when it comes to making it big or making things happen, you
need to define your calling. And once you've done that, it
comes down to the point that how, how bad you want it, which
we just spoke about. And then what's very important
is how not to overdo it. Because it's very well known
fact that too much of anything is bad, right?
If you, if you just keep on getting into that loop and then
it like it's, it's a spiral, which can quickly turn into
something counterproductive. So my question is that you have
fixed the first few steps where you are putting in the work, but
now how to not get bored of that work?
Is is that something that you've managed to unlock in your life,
or is change the only constant and that's why moving on to
something more exciting or different is the only way to
keep it alive? Oh, I really.
Yeah. This is.
It's incredible because you're touching on many points that I'm
reflecting on just generally my life and learning about myself
because yes, you know, a very good question again, And the the
reason being is because when I reflect on myself and my past
and my current situation is yes, I've always been obsessed with
what I'm currently involved in. And then I tend to do somewhere
in the region of 10 years worth of being very, very committed to
something and then everything changes again because I do love
change. You know, without going too
deeply into sort of philosophy and the understanding of self,
then what I can say, looking now back and reflecting and trying
to get a better understanding of my picture is we can chase these
things. They will almost certainly never
satisfy us regardless of what we're doing.
Because I am beginning to understand, or maybe it's not
understand. I'm beginning to want to create
an answer for myself, which is what the mime does.
It's great at creating answers that we want to align with and
that is basically that it doesn't matter what we try and
fill ourselves with, to become content and to have inner peace
is only going to come from within.
So no matter how much we try and do and what we try and do, you
know, if we want to become wealthy or if we want to make
flying our only thing and we just fly everyday, it still
isn't going to bring any form of true contentment.
The, the real feeling of content, being content with
yourself is going to come from within.
And it's probably going to come from some form of meditation
that requires nothing other than yourself and silence and the
ability to, to voyage within here and within here.
Everything exterior to that is just purely, not purely, I can't
say that sorry. It it could just be sensory
stimulation that we require to, to entertain ourselves until we
are ready to go on that sort of inner journey.
As such, I'm just becoming ready now to embark on this inner
journey where I am finding meditation and peace and quiet.
For instance, I was, I've, I've always been involved in exciting
sports. They have been what have driven
my life and what I've considered a value in my life.
Now I'm very much into gardening.
Why am I into gardening? Well, I don't really know, apart
from it's not as exciting as any of those sports.
It doesn't bring me any adrenaline, but at the same time
putting my hands in the earth and nurturing these plants and
trying to make this garden, this sort of mini food forest that
I'm trying to create has become a bit more of a passion because
it is fully tranquil and it doesn't require this stimulation
that I've been looking for in the past.
There's no adrenaline. There's just purely a peace that
it brings to my mind, to my being and enjoyment of just
watching it do what it does and helping it do what it does.
So it's very different to what I've used in the past as a
stimulation and this is now stimulating, but in a very
different way. Yeah.
OK. So this is something that I kind
of think about a lot myself because I mean the the
curiosities are similar, you know, from from what I've spoken
to you so far. One thing that I've realized or
discovered over a period of time is that, and I think this this
comes from Will Gad, who I had on my show back in the day as
well when I was just starting out.
And he said that it's the young ones who go out and make the
change, who push for something different than what it is.
So you need that testosterone to get the ball rolling.
But when I see sitting still or having the ability to sit down
with your thoughts and make peace with them, it's usually
the mature ones who are able to do it.
What I am wondering for a very long time is that is this just a
part of being human? That in the early years of your
life you will have all the excitement, the uneasiness or
the curiosities to go out and chase the adrenaline or whatever
you define it as. And then eventually nature slows
you down and you start making more peace with your reality.
That adrenaline or the the dissatisfaction that comes with
chasing adrenaline or that Cambridge chasing adrenaline can
come in other ways as well. So Long story short, is this
just a nature's way of making life complete as a human, or is
is this something that we as humans can particularly be aware
of? Where if you sit still as a
young person then you are going to be a cut above the wrist?
Because eventually it's the survival of the fittest which
makes the species go forward, right?
And if you are able to do something which the rest of the
gene pool is not doing, then you are definitely surviving better
than the others, yes. What's what's your thought on
that? Yes.
Well, I think, you know, we're we're about yeah, we're about to
get sort of slightly deeper on our philosophy, philosophical
understandings of life. I would say to try and wrap that
up in something that I think is the truth is that I think we're
born into a structured society that is very far from one that
is natural and we discover ourselves through whatever means
we can. And for me, you know, I, I was
never good at school. This is why I've come up with my
understanding of myself. I was never good at school
because I was put into a system that didn't suit me.
So when you're put into a system that doesn't suit you, but
you're beaten in that system, you know that that system is
your parents, That system you know, because the your parents
are in the system. But when that whole system
doesn't align with the natural true essence of a human life,
then we do all these things until finally we start to
recognise that all this is just noise.
And then you find the true path to the natural human life.
And that's why, yes, we could say it's the young ones that go
out and do this than the other. But in all honesty, I think that
everything is just a reaction from not living a true human
life. And, you know, a nurtured, we're
nurtured into competition rather than into harmony.
Why would we be nurtured into competition?
Well, because the whole of the modern society is basically
financial competition. So but that is far from anything
that is natural because we don't have to have it isn't actually
survival of the fittest. That's what we have to actually
understand as well. It is when you think of fittest,
we always think of, you know, the strongest.
The guy that got the no, no, it, it's the person who is able to
harmonise with the environment and the other people who becomes
the person who comes to the top because it's the person who is
closer to harmony is surviving better.
The person who is aggro and get out of my way, I'm climbing to
the top. He's not surviving very well
because he has to fight every day.
The person who harmonises every day is the fittest.
But it takes us a long time to understand and to get to that
harmony because we're bought into a system that is about
fighting. And it's not until we start to
mature and have the corners of ourselves knocked off through
these battles that we start to recognise that actually, you
know, at this present moment in time there are conflicts over
the world that are unfortunate. And I can now see the immaturity
in those conflicts because there can no, there can never be a
conflict that is won. There is.
Always going to be discontent and a so-called contentness from
the the, the, the, the successor, the the winner.
But if harmony isn't reached, nobody's really won.
You have to reach harmony because harmony is effectively
the only way forward. So yes, these expressions that
we have when we're younger and these things that we do are all
just a shakedown to eventually, hopefully find a harmonic rhythm
with yourself and the universe. How's that for you?
I love that we are connecting on such a harmonious level to begin
with. You know, I mean, it's, it's
amazing to have somebody open up to you and give you the trust to
have these conversations. The, the, the, the dilemma.
I wouldn't even say a question. Robbie, the dilemma.
And I'm going to take this a bit more personal, so bear with me,
my audience members. We will come back to the Flying
talk very soon. This is flying.
This is flying. You know, it's all an expression
of freedom. And we have to express
ourselves. We have to allow these things,
these ideas, you know, let your ideas fly.
It's the same thing as when you take off and you want to fly
across country, you know, you, you have to link the information
to be able to make the next thermal the next thermal.
Well, we also have to link the information within ourselves to
be able to make the next step in our evolution, in our personal
evolution to, to find, you know, if I, if I just came here for a
life and then didn't ever find something closer to harmony,
then I would be disappointed on my deathbed because I wouldn't
have achieved what I need to achieve.
What I need to achieve at some point in my life is a form of
harmony within myself, within the universe, within this life
where I feel that's it, I'm good, I'm content.
From here on, it's just icing on the cake.
And so we need to be talking about these things because in
the modern world, we're very muddled up in thinking that
achievement and success are things that are measured by
wealth and by the activities that we've LED in our life.
It's not the only only success can the only success that can
really be measured is at the end of your life, when the curtains
are about to be drawn or parted, whichever way you want to see
it, and you are content within yourself and you feel that
you've achieved what you should have achieved.
This, this. No, no, no, I love it.
I love it. It's just that I'm thinking
something super deep right now and I'm contemplating if it is
the right moment to share it or not because this is a public
quota and I'll be speaking to like this is this is going to be
an Internet forever. You know, there's not going
anywhere and people will listen to it.
But The thing is, I definitely, you know, have the trust with
you to feel comfortable enough to share with it.
Then I would request anybody who's listening to this to yeah,
like have a certain bit of yeah, just just judge it with your own
words. Because coming to Harmony, you
know, the, the thing that comes to my mind right now, as, as he
was speaking, I was thinking in my own head.
If at the end of the day, when it's time for the curtains, you
can say that yes, it's been a ride which you're happy with,
then that is a harmonious position to be in.
Recently I had the opportunity to experience something I would
say that I had wished and yearned and looked forward to
and visualized for decades, not even years, decades like you can
say ever since I was a kid, I wanted to do that.
And I'm talking about pilot shoot assist base from a
parallel letter. I mean, ideally, I like if you
ask me, my yearning was wingsuit base and that is still is that I
will go ahead and chase it. But for for the audiences who
are wondering, pilot chute assist base jump is basically
where there is someone else responsible for holding your
pilot chute while you jump out and that pilot chute opens up
the main canopy. And when you do it from pilot
lighters, there's practically not a lot of things that can go
wrong because you are in open space.
And even if there's a twist, because I have a pilot lighting
experiences, you can, you know, be with the risers.
And so they're very safe. First base jump of the life, I
would say, or a way to get into it.
I was in Lauterburger in Switzerland a few weeks ago and
I met a friend of mine randomly and he was jumping and I was
like, hey, man, so cool to see you.
And we ended up speaking and he was like, yeah, do you want to
jump? I was like, yeah, no, you know,
within, within a second, my answer was like, yes.
He was like, Are you sure you're you're you're going to trust me
just like that. And I was like that, not even a
question. Yeah.
Before the paraglider take off, when I was all rigged up, you
know, everything was good. Once a thought came to my mind
that I mean, I trust the technology, I trust my friend, I
trust the procedures. There's no question about having
a doubt right there. But then it's like, do anything
can happen to anyone at any time.
That is the norm of life. If it is the time to call it a
day, are you OK with the reward that you're chasing?
And somehow the answer was yes, Robbie.
I was OK with that, considering whatever I've done in the past
36 years of my existence on this planet.
Was that a harmonious position? Like, am I in harmony?
Is is that how you define something like that?
Well, it's risk to reward and I have taken many risks for the
reward because that was a lot of what I did for my life really.
You know, I've, I've done some base jumping and raced, raced
motorcycles and been a test pilot for, you know, 20 years
falling out of the sky and many incidents have, you know,
excitement and, and bravado. But I think I'm talking about
something slightly different where it's nothing to do with
you can deal with risk to reward because your desire for the
reward means that the risk is worth taking.
But sort of where I'm currently, it's just somewhere it's
slightly different because it's not about risk or anything.
It's not about risk to reward. It is purely about contentment
and finding, being content in with less, with nothing being
content with, you know, for instance, Once Upon a time my
life was, oh, I was so involved in my life that if I was in a
queue waiting for something to happen, yeah.
You know, if I had to wait in a queue and it was going to take
20 minutes, I would be uncomfortable for those 20
minutes because it's like, oh, come on, I've got, I've got
things to do. I, I could be doing this.
I could be doing that. Now the idea is to stand in that
queue and wait in that queue in line very comfortably within
myself, being able to meditate on the fact that this doesn't
matter, because it doesn't matter that it's going to take
me 20 minutes and I might miss something and the flight's going
to is going to take off and I'm not going to be on it.
Once Upon a time, that would have been a stress.
Oh my God, I'm going to miss the flight and oh God, you know,
that means I'm not going to get to the other end and the other
people that are waiting for me. It's all a pain in the neck.
Well, now I just stand there and wait for the for the line to go
down until it's my turn. And I try and be peaceful the
whole time rather than wanting or creating this thing within
me. And so that I'm just sort of
trying to, to, to get that, to, to find that harmony in
everything. You know, don't get me wrong,
I'm not getting, I don't get, I can't find this harmony
everywhere, but it's starting to search for it everywhere so that
I'm more present in the moment rather than yes, getting carried
away with the rewards. Yes, no matter how.
Yes, no matter how hard it is. God damn.
Yeah, but that doesn't, doesn't that make sense?
Because that that really is, you know, I, I, I'm going through
things at the moment that are not particularly comfortable.
But Once Upon a time it would have been much more
uncomfortable. But now I'm learning to to deal
with the discomfort and. Yeah, to find peace with it and
to harmonise with it because, because it's the best way.
You know, friction, whenever there's friction, you know, it's
so simple words, harmony, harmony and friction.
Harmony is only going to lead to contentment and some form of
comfort. Friction is not going to lead to
to that. And if you create friction and
you're creating one thing, and if you try and, you know, align
with harmony, you're getting something else.
So yeah, we we do have to try and harmonise and just be cool
with the way things are. OK, let's let's simplify it a
bit more for audiences who might be thinking, and I want to put
this in cross country terms. I think I know, like I was
speaking to a Parakite pilot the other day and he was like, why
do you even fly cross country? Man?
You guys land pissed all the time.
No matter. I think this is this is Paul
Tucker. I don't know who, but some guy,
a pretty big name in the industry named Benny Collin.
He was like cross country pilots land as sore losers every time
or most of the time and the Bob out Paris parakaiting is is so
much more fun. So anyways, what I'm trying to
say is that practice makes a man perfect with a very known very
well known saying. Long story short, the more you
practice dealing with your challenges, the more the better
you get at navigating them. Is like to to put it in simpler
words, first breakup hurts the most and later on it doesn't
that bad. So the more you do it the better
you get at it. Is that the bottom line of life?
Well, only if you're searching to become better at it, yes, But
the search to become better at it has to be a conscious search.
Otherwise, no, it'll just, you know, and The thing is that I,
I, there's no right or wrong in life.
There is just individual journeys and everybody's
entitled to their own journey. And some people may desire to
chase the adrenaline buzz to the end.
Great, Well, that's fantastic. Good.
Good luck with that. I hope you enjoy it.
And really, I mean, that's great.
Other people might not want to recognise it whatsoever.
Everything's personal. So the guy who wants to fly
across country, go and fly across country and enjoy it.
If you land out, if you land at your end of your cross country
and you're not satisfied, well, that's unfortunate.
You're probably not doing the right thing.
And the guy who's flying the para kite or whatever, you know,
it, it's maybe less adventurous because it's more limited in
terms of being on a hill doing, you know, practising manoeuvres.
It's not quite as expansive as cross country flying.
But yes, you know, everybody writes their own story and it's
up to them what they're looking for.
Everybody gets to write their own ending too.
So you know, it, it depends what, what, how do you want your
book to read? Do you want it to read the same
from start to finish? Or do you want there to be a
progression in the book towards something?
I Yeah. And, and some people want to
read a book that's the same from start to finish and other people
want to read a book that has progression.
So that's what I'm saying. There's no, there isn't one
thing for everybody. There's just an individual
journey, But I'm interested in my individual journey being
layers of different things. So, and hopefully this is just,
you know, as I said with the garden, it's another layer.
And I think it's a very good layer for me to have because a
lot of my life has just been adrenaline junkie type
satisfaction. So and now I'm looking into
different kinds of satisfaction, meditation, different kind of
satisfaction. My mind is very active.
So to try and overcome my mind is really enjoyable, you know?
Having a good day. It's fun to see the smile that
code puts puts on your face. It's it's like, yeah, you're
aware of how to make it count, but let's say what was I going
to say? Yes, if it feels right in the
moment, then no matter how loud the questions are, to me, it
feels that it's worth continuing what you're doing because of
course you can, you know, overthink any of your goals or
aims and like keep on remunerating on your past.
But if like living in the moment is the ultimate Nirvana, right
where you're not kind of swamped by thoughts which are beyond
your control, so be it like chasing the lead goggle or be it
pushing full bar when you're at the back.
If it feels right when you're doing it, you're doing it the
right way. Is is, is this the essence of
life? More or less?
Umm, well, yes, I mean, I, I, I'm not the guy.
I don't know the essence of life.
Who knows what it is. Again, everything's so
individual because everyone's experience is their own
experience. I can't say what's right or
wrong. I know that I have been, you
know, these sports, especially when we flying, for instance, is
very meditative in the state of just flying because as, as we
all know, every pilot knows this is that you can have the weight
of the world on your shoulders and literally you take off and
suddenly that's all gone. And you are just in a meditate
meditative state where you're just thinking about flying and
how to, you know, where to control your wing, how to
control it. So that takes us into this
meditative state. But it's also a good indication
to show us that the that that meditation and let's say
unadulterated meditation is probably something that we
should all be paying attention to, but we don't.
We like, let's say, excited meditation.
Where you are. Yeah, where, where you're, where
your mind is consumed with something greater than your
problems, but it is still consumed with something, you
know, as you know, true meditation is to try and not be
consumed with anything, you know, if you can.
It's a great step, but I, I don't necessarily think that
it's, you're doing the right thing.
You are just doing a thing. And it, it just so happens that,
you know, for us, when you're going paradeliding, it feels
good because we are in a form of meditation that takes us away
from the problems that we have in the real world.
But to be able to sit still with yourself and be able to get into
that meditative state and push all those problems aside and
yes, and just deal with yourself there and try and find silence,
then, then that's a whole different, different ball game.
Deep. Very deep.
Well, you know, when I look at my life and my sports, I know
how much they have distracted me from the real world of the the
rest of the world because they're so, you know, they, they
draw you in, they're amazing. You know, flying on a beautiful
day or, you know, not on a necessarily beautiful day, but
trying to fly your best in conditions that aren't very
good. You're going to be just fully
engrossed in receiving as much information as you can trying to
apply it, apply all the knowledge you have to, to be
able to make the right decisions to make that this flight last
longer or to try and be first or, you know, faster to the
goal. Yeah, it's super consuming.
It's amazing what what you can do with flight.
I'm so glad that like the first 40 minutes of this talk, we have
built up a huge ass base to everything that we exchanged on
emails, you know, because the, the, the topics on e-mail was
like finding your passion, finding the courage, making it
sustainable, giving up to the community, everything.
So we have discussed everything that comes outside that scope.
And you know, maybe now we can use the the future moments to
reflect more on that which is more flying related.
But before we do that, Robbie, there was a question that I
wanted to ask you earlier rather than speaking about harmony.
And to me, let's let's, let's put another word to it, which
can be called as fitting in into the ecosystem and blending in.
You can say that, right? If you're sticking out, then
you're read it out. If you blend in then you roll
with the tribe. Basically my question to you,
which is something that I have. I think I've found the answer to
it but I would love to get your perspective.
Long story short, obsessed with flying, doing whatever to take
to make it to do, doing whatever it takes to to make it happen
and moving to a whole different country and society was brutal
change in my reality when it comes to expectation versus, you
know, the real thing. And I tried to blend in, man.
I gave it my all. I kid you not, I, I tried to
behave like, you know, be in be like Romans when in Rome.
I, I lived that saying as much as I could.
I'm not saying that I lived it to the perfection, but I gave it
my all. And eventually I saw that I was
losing myself in, in, in search of blending in.
Yeah, uh, then, umm, some things showed me in life that being
yourself is so much more fun. It, it makes you smile more
often. So why not go back to that?
And even if it doesn't mean that you're in perfect harmony with
your surroundings, which are brand new, not not your
ancestors because my ancestors and my tribe where I originated
from are on the other side of the planet.
Yet I umm, one of the, you know, you can say a lone wolf who
decides to put all his eggs in one basket and try to make sense
of the actuality. And in that I've gone on extreme
ends of the scales and eventually found out that being
in harmony is helpful as long as it doesn't eat you up, like
doesn't go as long as you don't go to self destruct mode,
basically where you start losing yourself.
So finding first of all, is this the right way?
Because that is the only vein which one sets in my head.
And if it is, then how do you find the courage to reach this
realization? Because there is a right time to
give up in some endeavours, in some pursuits, and especially if
these pursuits come at a cost of giving up on your inherent like
desires, like the instincts, basal instincts, then it's about
time you speak to yourself honestly rather than continuing
with, you know, a straight head and not looking around and being
aware. Because I'm not sure if I
explained it correctly. What do you get the vibe that
I'm trying to say here? Yeah, yes.
Is it totally. And it just brings me back to as
you know, what I was saying earlier that the journeys and
the paths are all different. And what we can definitely say
is, you know, with the blending in as such.
One of the probably the one of the most destructive things in
modern, well, not in modern society, in any society, is this
idea of wanting to fit in. Because wanting to fit in is
purely, well, wanting to fit in is not recognising that
everybody is an individual. And by fitting in, most of the
time it is to emulate somebody else or something else.
And one thing that we don't do, I believe, and I've always
thought this, I've thought this for a long, long time, because I
didn't fit in in the beginning, because I, I was, yeah, I, I was
just a kid who shouldn't have been in school, you know, I, I,
yeah, I didn't fit in that system.
So if you don't fit in that system, you, you, you grow up
recognising that, you know, following fashion and being like
everybody else isn't actually what you want to do.
You're an individual here. You're allowed to express
yourself as you want. You should.
We should all be proud to be individuals and to have our own
thought processes and our own thought patterns.
And regardless of what stage we're at in our lives, you know,
you've got to be, or at least you don't have to be, but it's
good to be, to recognise your individual traits and, and
strengths and, and weaknesses too.
You know, obviously we've all got strengths and weaknesses,
but everything else, unfortunately to me is just a
form of societal constraint really.
And yes, I, I wouldn't want to move to another country and then
try and be, you know, I, I wouldn't want to move to Rome
and then be, try and be a Roman. I'm not I'm me.
It's OK when you think of the, the globe or the world and it is
basically one big rock and you take away the oceans and it is
only one rock. We're all connected to the same
place. Everybody is connected to this
rock. And it doesn't matter where
you're born on this rock, you're still just a human being, an
individual human being doing your thing.
That's what we should be embracing and allowing it to to
happen like that. But unfortunately that isn't
where we're at. And so society tells us it's,
you know, when in Rome and act like the omens.
Well, why whose whose great idea was that?
So that you don't you don't get seen and you don't live the life
that's true to yourself. You you simulate theirs because
you think that's the thing to do.
Well, you know what happened to the Roman Empire when it went
down the shedder? Well, it did, you know, as they
all do, because we're not, we're not living individual lives that
promote the best of ourselves. We we end up getting corralled
into societies that apparently don't benefit anyone because in
the end, they all fall apart and collapse and then there's a
rebirth and off we go again. So, yeah, it's all very
difficult to to navigate. And I always think on the side
of the individual because I want to be that individual within
myself and within the things that I do.
The only thing I want to harmonise with is with nature.
I don't necessarily want to harmonise with societal
constraints because that's not to me.
That's not harmonising. Harmonising with a constraint
isn't harmony. Harmonising with nature,
harmonising with the universe, That's what we need to be doing.
Or at least I need to be doing. Thank you for hitting the nail
on the head, Robbie, you, you sold a dilemma there.
I don't think that's the dilemma.
Maybe. For you.
Yeah, yeah, yeah. That's what I'm saying.
Like it's harmonizing with nature is greater than
harmonizing with society. As simple as that.
Oh, yes, yeah. Well, look, what we have to
realise is that what goes on in your head is nothing different.
That's what's gone in, gone in, gone on in everybody.
Well, it is different, but you know this, this indoctrination
that we've had, this indoctrination that takes away
our ability to think critically, to, to live from our heart, to
live from our stomach where you know, you, you know what's right
and wrong, but you go and do the things you shouldn't do because
everybody else is doing them. You know, the greatest indicator
for me of anything is if everybody else is doing it, I
don't want to be doing it. I don't care what it is, you
know, let's just say COVID vaccine, when it's being pushed
down your throat that hard, then there's something wrong.
You don't you don't want to be doing that.
For instance, the World Cup, when the World Cup suddenly is
the biggest thing around the globe and it's this, everybody's
supporting their team and their way.
You know, our country wins. Well, I don't want any part of
the World Cup, you know, I just, I'm not interested because it,
it's all the indoctrination stuff, you know, imagine if they
put as much emphasis on trying to look after your own back
garden as much as they do on on the World Cup.
For instance, how many hours did you spend in front of the
television for the World Cup? How many hours did you spend in
your garden? Well, you probably spent more on
the World Cup but less in your garden.
You know, it's all, it's all topsy turvy, it's all madness,
you know. So yes, when when everybody's
doing something, the the chances are you should be doing exactly
the opposite. Reminds me of the famous Pink
Floyd song. We don't mean no education.
Yes. One of the greats say you're
playing at some and this is just like, yes.
Yeah, that's like I, I'm pretty sure.
Like there's a whole generation after generation of people who
can relate to the lyrics and, you know, kudos to the artists
who put in the. Well, yes.
Generation after generation. Hey, teacher, leave those kids
alone. Yeah, it's very fitting in
today's times because not only does it mean mentally, but it
also means physically. And you know, we are in a mad
time where everything's going on and you know, you, you steal and
you drive. You can drive a person's life by
being a bad teacher or a good teacher.
But as we know, the system isn't particularly good.
So it doesn't matter if you're a good teacher or a bad teacher.
You're still indoctrinating those kids to to not understand
the freedom of mind. I, I love the word, the
terminology that you use that you can drive other people
because it's such a powerful responsibility if you have the,
you know, the blessing to drive someone else's wife.
As a teacher makes me curious because these days one of the
drivers of a lot of people's reality is social media,
unfortunately. Like holy shit, how, how do
people not realise that it, it actually dictates the way you
move around your day and not just the way you think.
So I'm, I'm curious, have you ever scrolled in your life?
Have you ever? Yes, I have.
Yeah. You know, I've got.
We're all bombarded by this and I have, you know, the same
problems as anybody else. This, this technology has been
devised by very clever people to suck us all in.
I am very anti telephone, mobile phone in general.
I try and leave it at home a lot or I do leave it at home a lot.
I use it as a tool for myself, but it doesn't mean to say that
I'm constantly available. So I it can ring and I can just
ignore it because I don't care who's on.
There's nothing that's that important that I need to pick it
up. I'll pick it up if I want to
pick it up, but if I don't want to pick it up, I don't care
who's calling. I don't care if it.
I just don't care because it's all noise.
Once Upon a time, 20-30 years ago, everybody got on with their
lives without them. Then suddenly they, they became
very in our lives. And then today, you know, I
travel around the world and I see everybody at the airport
just doing this. No one's looking at books
anymore. They're all just staring into
their phones, young and old alike.
So yes, I, I do get caught up in that.
I try not to be too bad. I try to make sure that my feed
is very positive and I've got lots of nature stuff, lots of
gardening stuff, lots of sort of stretching and isoteric stuff,
basically, you know, stuff that's actually stimulating.
I don't need to go down the the world of modern news and drama.
Quick question, very respectfully, because this is
something that I that I feel so challenged explaining.
My mum as well, probably she's a bit older than you.
She says the same thing that you know what, I'm scrolling and I'm
looking at cooking video, then I'm looking at fashion and
whatever. So whatever she's scrolling is
making sense in her head. And I think I've spoken to, I've
spoken about this on the show earlier.
So maybe some of the audience members know the reference that
I'm know know the topic that I'm referring to is that as you
mentioned that there are proper scientists who have designed the
algorithm and they release, they make you feel in a certain way
when you make that movement with your hand over the touch of the
screen. My realization is, Robbie, that
you cannot learn while you are getting intoxicated.
I mean, of course you can, but it won't be that effective.
Like, you know, imagine going to a class with a beer in your
hand. It's like, yeah, you know what
The the instructor can, can speak whatever he wants to, and
I'll keep on sipping a beer while I'm learning.
It's going to be a lot more counterproductive.
So what I'm saying is that bottom line of scrolling is that
no matter how much sense it makes in your own head, it is
still intoxicating you at the time of receiving it.
So isn't giving up the only end game there because everything
else is still intoxication at the end of the day?
Yes, absolutely. And I have been contemplating
over the last probably two months, actually getting rid of
the mobile phone because it's very apparent where we're
heading. You know, I, you could call me
some kind of, some kind of tech rejection.
Maybe that's true. I don't particularly, you know,
not, not not all technology is good.
And we, we prove that to ourselves repeatedly.
For instance, a nuclear bomb, it, it's cutting edge
technology. And I'll look at the way wars
are fought today with drones and you know, all this, all this
technology is making killing people, let's say, easier.
That's not. Useful.
It's not good technology. Yeah, it's technology.
It's the same stuff that's that's in these phones.
And so not all tech is good. We can safely say that you and I
both know and all the the listeners and watchers know that
that mobile phone is useful as a mobile phone.
It's awesome. But everything else that it
does, we don't need. We never needed it.
It's just that we were sold it and now we've been sold the idea
that we can't live without it. And now they're going to have a
society in probably less than 10 years where you are going to
have to have one. Can you imagine that this
appendage is going to almost be mandatory?
That to me is incredibly worrying because no part of that
is natural. No part of it is actually
required. The the, the ability to be able
to make a call quickly when you need to make a call or receive 1
communicate is awesome, but it's gone way past communication
that's now control. So yeah, it's it's interesting.
It's very interesting. I mean, bottom line that I'm
trying to tell our audiences is that no matter how much collapse
videos or, you know, crazy things that you might be
watching, which might be making sense in your own head, bottom
line is that it is counterproductive and it's not
going to get you where you think it will.
It's a, it's a pseudo effect that makes you think it'll get
you in, get you there. And then eventually once that,
once you're physically tired, because I think that is the only
barrier that the big tech has not broken yet, that the human
body has a physical limit. And like eventually people get
tired of holding a phone physically.
I mean, they all the eyes get too tired.
So once you do that, once the dopamine goes back to the
baseline, it goes lower, it goes higher.
The baseline is higher than what it was before you picked up the
phone. So try giving it up no matter
how much you think you're learning.
I can share 1 anecdote which stuck with me while I was
chasing this pursuit of like lifestyle.
I would say because it's a it's a huge discipline challenge to
give up scrolling simply because of the fact of how how good it
feels. How I made sense with it is that
saying yes to things is fun. I'm not going to lie, saying yes
to things which are counterproductive or which are
not healthy is so much fun, man. Go grab a beer, drink it, watch
your head get light or chase the rush in any form, you know, be
it, be it a hookup, be it a snort, be it whatever, whatever
rocks your world. But try saying no.
And the first few times it might not be fun, but I kid you not,
after, after you've crossed that barrier, saying no is even more
fun than saying yes. You know, that's where the bliss
is. Yes, you've struck it on the
head for me. That is exactly where it's at.
And an interesting one for you is that for the last 10 years
now, I think it's 10 years. It could be 8 years, but I think
it's 10. I kept, I've been saying 8 years
for a long time, but I think it's probably about 10 years
now. I've been eating one meal a day.
It's the joy of saying no and it's the success of saying no.
And it's, and that's also turned into alcohol and other things
that it's I just again, when it's recognising these traits
that society builds for us to align with, but then realising
that they're wrong. So it's pretty obvious that
three meals a day of the type of food we're eating at this
particular juncture in time is not very good for people because
you only have to look around to see everybody's pretty.
Not everybody, but the majority of people are overweight and
unhealthy and unfit. And.
You can eat yourself, fit, literally eat less.
Your cellular restorative system can only click into action
basically if you're intermittent fasting, if you're eating three
meals a day on a cellular level, your restorative system can
never start. So once you understand these
things and then you realise that the food industry and the
Pharmaceutical industry are owned by each other and they're
invested in each other, we sell more food, which is great for
us. And you selling the people more
food means that they're going to need more drugs to try and solve
the health issues that the more food is creating, especially the
low quality food that they're that we're selling them.
So these two things go together and it's an ever decreasing
circle of life. Your life is going to get worse
as you get fatter and more unhealthy and as you get older
and older. It's an accumulation of your
entire life's consumption and they're throwing drugs at you
just to relieve the symptoms. And yeah, lo and behold, it's a
great system for people to make money.
But I said no to that. And it's just such an enjoyable
thing to feel fantastic within myself to be saying no on a
regular basis, to enjoy saying no.
When I do get to 6:00 PM in the evening and I have my evening
meal, then yes, I give myself a pat on the back.
I made it. Well done.
Nice, nice. You won the battle again, and it
is a battle because it's a battle against the
indoctrination and the reduction of your potential.
So just like the mobile phone, this is a reduction of your
potential because it's going to chew hours of your life that you
could have been putting into yourself, but instead you're
just going to flick and scroll and go nowhere.
Oh, yeah. But that's interesting.
I didn't know about that. Yeah, but what are you going to
do with that information? You know you're not going to do
anything with it, so even though you've got some new information,
you're not going to do anything with it, so it doesn't make any
difference anyway. So yeah.
It's going to vanish anyways out of your head, you know as soon
as you put on the phone to go the way it is designed to.
Yeah, when you go to your next scrolling session, you'll have
forgotten what you got, what you learnt from the last one anyway.
So yeah, yeah, it's another one of those things when everybody's
doing something, you need to be doing some the opposite.
So if everybody's looking in this, you probably don't need to
be looking at it. If everyone's eating three meals
a day, chances are you don't need to be eating three meals a
day. If alcohol has been made
socially acceptable and everybody's drinking it, good
chance you don't need to be drinking it.
Let me put that into paragliding contest.
If the gaggle is going one way, there is probably a better left.
Somebody's just got to be brave enough to go.
There are multiple ways, but there's the way everybody's
doing it or there's the way you can do it.
You just don't have to go the same route and it might take a
little bit longer. There's no doubt that the the
mobile phone makes things at particular instances quicker,
but the result, you can still get the same result by walking
to a public telephone, putting a coin in and making a call.
It's it still gets the same result, but one of them took an
action, whereas this, this one takes less action and it's just
handy and it's here. And then we build up a whole
love story with this because it's socially acceptable now
it's socially unacceptable to go and make it all on a public
phone. Oh, but they're dirty.
The whole world's dirty. If you think the phone's dirty,
what about everything else that you touched during the day?
Come. On yeah.
And I'd like to reinforce the gaggle analogy here because I
was speaking to Juan Serbospina, who's one of the British
goodbyes, who's racing and the Europeans as we speak right now.
And we were just discussing top Frenchies and like Maxine and
honor and and stuff like that. And he was like, dude, because I
was like, man, what is it that Honoren has that he keeps on
killing it every single time. And he was like, man, you have
no idea how many times I have seen him bomb out and make
mistakes. So the point is, the point that
I'm trying to make is that even though the gaggle goes one way,
Honorens and Maxines and goes, or even 1 for that matter, are
the few brave ones who go out and carve their own path.
And they might fail because obviously risk comes with
whatever, you know what I'm saying.
But when they do succeed, they learn something so great that
others don't even have the courage to open the book for in
that learning. And eventually, once courage
becomes a habit, these kind of challenges become a bliss
because for everyone else it's a challenge, but for you, it's
something that's your comfort zone.
So following the guy that is fun, it's a part of the tribe
and you feel safe. You can see the air more.
But eventually the glory lies in pushing your comfort zone and
that you have to define yourself on how much glory you want
basically. It's being prepared to try.
Don't get me wrong, it's still difficult to fly in the gaggle
that it's the way that modern day competition is.
It's incredible. The the gaggle is incredibly
fast, but you have to try and these guys go out and they try
and sometimes they succeed, sometimes they don't.
But they're they're giving it a go.
And yes, it's safer to stay in the gaggle, but you know, you're
learning so much and you're not learning less, but you're just,
you're not taking a risk. You're not pushing yourself.
You're not pushing the, you're not pushing against the system.
It's the guy that goes out there and finds the next thermal.
Oh yeah, now we'll follow him. Now we'll follow him.
You're only following. And following still, like I say,
is not easy. But you want to be the guy that
is being followed. That's where the fun is.
Oh, yeah, Yeah. Robbie, how do I even comprehend
this? One hour.
This is supposed to be a paragliding talk now, but we did
everything, Yes. We talk about paragliding.
We can quickly, we can do a quick 10 minutes about
paragliding and then you can cut the pieces together.
Yeah, post production is always fun listening to her.
The thing is, it's interesting, but what are the good thing is
you have plenty of people talking about paragliding.
So not every podcast needs to be fully integrated into into
paragliding. It's better that there's a, you
have a wide, a wide library of if you want to just go full
flying, then there's Oh yeah, look at this one.
If you want to go a little bit more to the lunatic end, then
there's this one. No, that was the essence of
starting the show. In the beginning, I was like,
yes, I don't want to hit just one nail on the head.
I want to put multiple ones and make sure all of them or at
least try my own bit and then let everything else fall into
place by itself. But coming back to our topic,
Robbie and you do have time, is there?
Yes, absolutely. OK, great.
Because Simon again, I've been thinking what is the most
optimum duration for episode? And because Spotify has its own
algorithm and as a creator, I get bombarded with suggestions
from their e-mail team on how to make it make it the best.
But then I was like, as long as it feels right, that is the
duration that I should be chasing.
I agree. So coming back to the doing your
calving, your own parts, I've been very curious to ask you
this. Robbie, you guys, you are one of
the early founders of Ozone and God damn man, that being one of
the inventors of the most iconic brand in the sport.
How does it feel Robbie? How does it feel when you guys?
Look back and see what you have created.
Yes, very lucky for sure. Yeah, the whole ozone story is
quite amazing. Please talk us through it.
I'd love to, honestly. Well.
So it basically started. I was interested in starting a
brand with my brother and then we bumped into bumped into Mike
Kavanagh was a British team manager at the time and we just
got chatting one evening and I was working at Firebird at the
time. Mike was busy being an
accountant at a newspaper and Dave Pilkington was around on
the scene working at Airwave and in back in the early days as
well. Bruce Goldsmith was involved and
yeah, it was just passionate people deciding to do it
themselves because maybe we didn't have full agreement with
the the people that we were working with and we thought we
could do it better in a nicer way.
And Ozone was born, really. It was fantastic.
We didn't last long with Bruce. So just difficulties so that we
parted ways and me, Mike and Dave just got stuck into it and
it was fantastic. And the main reason it was
amazing was because Dave is very good at what he did and Mike was
exceptional at what he did, which is the the business side
of things. Dave was the sort of production
side of things. And I was the ended up being
design and testing because I was already in testing especially.
And it's just turned into what it has through diligence of
management really. And it's, it's a lovely thing.
And I'm glad that ozone is what it is.
And it does what it does, which is try to inspire, tries to have
good business practice. We're, we set up our own
production in Vietnam. We treat those people amazingly
well. I've heard that before.
The scene is president stuff. Yeah, we're just the factory is
Dave did just such an Dave and Young, his wife did such an
amazing job over there. It's like it's super clean and
it's all air conditioned. They take the the whole staff,
the whole place on holiday. Each year there's 1000 workers
taking thousand people on holiday.
Yeah, there's medical insurance, there's dental insurance,
there's accommodation for people that come in from the provinces.
There's, it's just doing it properly, doing it the right way
and looking after everybody that's in our ecosystem, looking
after our distribution network, just trying to trying to have a
healthy business and trying to promote a healthy sport and a
healthy sport means that we can have a healthy business and a
healthy business means we can have a healthy sport.
They both go together, symbiotic relationship and we're not
really in competition with anybody because there is no real
competition without anybody else.
There's only competition within yourself to do a better job.
Yes, for sure they may, they've been making great gliders, David
Daggau and the and Russ and the Luke.
They've just employs great people.
There's a good work ethic, there's an enjoyment, a shared
passion. It's just it's amazing.
It's amazing. Yes, yeah, it's come good.
And I hope that people feel that the brand is giving back, which
I believe it is. It's invested in competitions
for everybody. It invests some of its profits
back into the environment, environmental things that
environmental causes. And yeah, it's just, it's a good
thing. It shows that not all business
has to revolve around the bottom line and in profit, it can
revolve around trying to be healthy for everybody involved.
It reminds you of the militant Friedman Coat.
The business of doing business is just about business, which is
basically comes down to the money, and that was the
stupidest shit I've ever heard in my life.
And Boeing proves that super well with everything that is
going on in the company because they live for Wall Street and
stuff. I think a good example is
longevity. The longer a company is around
proves the health of the business really.
But again, we are also dealing with a sport and one of the best
things about our sport is that it's becoming safer and that
safety is helping the whole sport have a better public
image. And so the late 80s, early 90s,
it blew up, but then it collapsed because there was a
lot of injuries, because people now it's had time to mature.
The actual sport has had time to mature and the safety matches
the maturity of the sport. So people can come into the
sport, learn well, learn safely. We know the best techniques to
teach people depending on where they're learning so they have
good experience. Then they come into a sport
that's mature enough and a system that is or an ecosystem
that helps them progress. There's a lot of the club at a
club level, even the clubs now are very safety conscious and
promoting sort of better flying practice.
So yeah, the whole thing is just it's come of age really paradigm
and came of age and Ozone was lucky to be there at the right
time, but also has been a good part of it coming of age as
well. Before I jump on next question,
Robbie, the name Ozone is quite fascinating.
What's the story behind your name?
The story behind the name is we were struggling to find the name
and John Pendry came up with ozone and John was obviously a
big part of my early years in Hang Gliding and paragliding.
And John was somewhat, somewhat involved with us at the
beginning. Should we say he never worked
with us or but was a good friend and a sponsored pilot and things
like that? And John came up with the name
Ozone. And yeah, that's a great name.
I don't think we thought into it enough quite enough at the time,
but it worked. And here we are today with with
Ozone. So he just said just because of
the ozone layer, it just sounds cool enough to.
I don't even know if it was. It was just the name sounded
right. We've been throwing a few
minutes around and that one came up.
It's like, Oh yeah. Do you remember the ultimatums?
Oh God no. I can't remember any of the
alternatives. Really fun to to picture what
the industry you like. Yes, it was.
In In fact, I don't know if we hadn't really been thinking
about it much, but John just came up with that and it stuck.
It was like, yeah, that's a great name.
One thing that I'm very curious, Robbie, is that making mistakes
or stumbling while you're on your part is a part of human
nature. None of us is God.
We all are mortals and we all make mistakes.
How did you guys navigate the challenging times?
How did you guys make sure that instead of falling, I wouldn't
say apart, but letting that crisis grow into something big
and you guys managed to find a way up and kept going?
Yes, there are always challenging times, problems that
come along. In all honesty, I think that
most of those challenging times have been well managed by Mike
Kavanagh. Mike is a very level headed cool
guy. He doesn't, he doesn't instantly
react, which is obviously a very good thing because most of our
when you have problems that knee jerk reactions and reacting too
quickly are often not the best thing to do.
But Mike is just very diligent and very calm.
So he made very good decisions. And the same thing with Dave and
the production side of things. It's 1000 people means that
you've got to have a business that is continually, how do you
say continually afloat and sustainable because we don't
want to sack staff and then re employ staff and because our
market, because we're not stable in the market, everything is
about being stable. But again, when you treat people
well, we try and treat our dealer network well.
We try and treat the schools well.
We're trying to enhance the sport.
Everything is put in there to try and make it run smoothly.
Yeah, it's all worked relatively well because yeah, we're every
hurdle that we've come up against so far has been possible
to surpass and we got over it and carried on.
But like I say, mainly down to Mike's cool nature and not
getting overexcited about things that we can you can deal with.
Have you guys had any ethical dilemmas?
Because I remember watching a documentary and Google or
something and they said that when they were going forward
they had. A challenge where they wanted to
push, I mean I don't know, they had a choice of being something
that was not OK to show to the people versus something which
was perfectly fine. And then they said that we will
mix and match both of them on the search results so that we
are not on the either end of the scale.
Their search between an ethical dilemma was that the safe part
in middle part and that we don't have to scale the guilt.
But that also meant that they were going a bit worse despite
of ignoring complete public welfare or whatever it is.
I hope you can get the point that I'm saying, but how did you
have you guys had to reach those kind of crossroads where it was
like if we do this, then the community as a whole might not
benefit as much. If we do this, then they will,
but we as a company will have to sacrifice something.
So if yes, then how have you guys navigated around those?
I think, you know, I don't know that anything has particularly
come up that has put us in that position.
Most of the time of course, the company's survival as such is is
going to be effectively first in line.
So that's, and most of the time it's because we're trying to
protect our staff more than anything.
There's a, there's 1000 people depending that if you think that
there's 1000 people depending directly on what we do, that
means there's probably somewhere in the region of 3000 people in
total, maybe more 5000 that that are even more than that.
So there's a lot of people dependent on that.
So we're probably try and do the best, what is best for them
first, secondly, but also almost on an equal level, what's good
for the sport because one doesn't come without the other.
The sport needs to be healthy for us to have a healthy
business within the sport and vice versa.
Yes, when it comes to anything ethical like that, I think yeah,
yeah, we try and do our best on all fronts.
As I said, I think that's part of the success of Ozone is that
at the end of the day, it's a business, but it's a business
that isn't. It's a business that is
investing in the sport and in yeah, it's investing in the
sport. So I think that keeps us
relatively honest because we've got to, we have to have a sport
to have a business. Yeah, so Long story short,
self-interest is a necessity but becomes an existential crisis.
But if that is not the case, then you can look for means
beyond your own, but survival is a necessity.
And then? Yeah, yes, it is.
But I don't think you've got to understand that Mike and Dave,
especially Ozone is not a cutthroat business.
So at the end of the day, if ozone had to close for the
benefit of the sport to continue, then I guess they'd
probably do that. I don't think it's ever going to
come to that. But they're just, yeah, I, yeah,
it's a difficult question, but I think that most of the time it's
like you say, business has to survive to a certain to an
endpoint, but then you can go past that endpoint.
But the sport needs to survive most importantly as well.
You know, this brings me to Armstrong Foils, if you'd let me
touch on that. And for audiences who are
wondering, Armstrong Armstrong Foils is another brand which
Robbie got into as a founder, as a Co founder, I would say once
he found his new calling of some sorts.
And it, it has grown into again, one of the most successful
foiling brands out in the market simply because of the way you
tackle. So when you when you were
speaking with your partner, I'm forgetting his name.
I was listening to his podcast yesterday.
Oh, Amy Armstrong, Amy. Yes.
He said that you were like key factor in mailing the foil
design and stuff like that. What were the lessons that you
took from Ozone that you implemented there that helped
you leapfrog the competition if any?
First of all, it is a statement, correct?
And if yes, then how did you navigate that?
How do you manage them? If anything, it's it's a good
question. It's difficult to answer.
Basically, there are just so many after having so many years
of business, successful business with Ozone and seeing what
works, not being cutthroat in business.
It's a very good thing because. Please explain from the
audience. Sorry, cutthroat means that it's
not business at all cost. OK, Yeah.
You have to, you have to nurture the sport.
And so from the beginning, Armstrong has been involved in
the sport and sharing, as with Ozone, sharing the passion
because the one thing that's really interesting, especially
with pilots, and it's also the same with the ocean.
It's a special breed of people that want to go flying.
Most people do not want to go flying.
It's a special breed in the ocean doing water sports.
It's the same thing. Not everybody wants to go into
the ocean and do water sports. So you have to realise that this
is your, it's, it's your, it's your brotherhood, iron
brotherhood, the ocean user brotherhood.
And everybody is sharing the same passion.
They like this escape, make the escape and the the enjoyment of
these sensations that we are chasing a part of your business
because that's what we're all that's all we're out there for.
The actual para glider who makes it doesn't matter.
It's the fact that this thing allows us to get this feeling
that filled with yes, that's what I took from there.
And admittedly, I think the passion thing with Ozone was one
of my creations because of something that I helped shape a
lot. Because passion is so important.
It's the driving factor. It's our love for this sport
that started the business. It wasn't because we wanted to
have a business that made money in the power lighting sport.
It's because we loved flying when we started Armstrong.
It's because we loved foiling. It was just like, yeah.
And it started with friends and it started and Armstrong started
with friends. It's not like we just got
together to make a business to make money.
Yes, we just enjoy and promote passion really and that it seems
to be a good recipe. That's the key.
That's the key tagline there. Enjoy and promote passion.
Rest. Everything else falls into place
if you work hard enough. Yeah, yeah.
And it is tons of hard work. That's the other thing people
may not recognise that is hours and hours of dedicated life and
work time. Weekends disappear, holidays
don't exist. You can ask anybody that knows
me your whole life is the one thing.
But it's OK. It's OK because it's super
enjoyable and you're creating things that you want to create.
You're sharing a feeling that you want to share.
And if you at the end of the day as well, sorry.
One other thing I remembered is there's no hard selling.
We don't need to sell the products.
We want people to buy the products.
If they like the products, we don't need to force them down
the throat and we don't need to have cutthroat sales tactics or
anything. It's just this is our feeling
that we're trying to create. We want to share that feeling.
These are the tools that we share those feelings with and if
you like them, fantastic. If you don't like them and you
like another manufacturer's feeling, great, go and enjoy
their feeling. We don't.
It doesn't matter. Just be there enjoying it,
whatever it is, and if it's our stuff, fantastic.
If it's someone else's, fantastic.
I'm smiling so hard because you just seem so peaceful by saying
that feeling like and I love the way you explain it because I've
watched you guys for quite a while with your media presence.
I I wouldn't shy away from taking names because what I've
seen is advance in New York's, which are one of the biggest
competitors, at least in the beginning class of gliders are
killing it and marketing the teams that they have which push
push out content is absolutely a delight to see in paragliding
the newsletters that come your way, the promotions that happen
on every platform. And then there's ozone.
I wouldn't say they don't give a single about that.
They do. But some, I don't know who was
it Russ or was it Bill Belkert or somebody told me that Ozone's
philosophy is just make the rings that people like to fly
and then everything else falls into everything else.
They'll get itself out, basically.
Yeah. That's inspiring considering I
have been wanting to go out and I'm starting my own business in
trail tours and travels and I will be launching.
How about in trips? And I'm looking at all sorts of
these marketing templates and those kind of things.
But I'm like, bottom line is dude, if your vibe is amazing,
then you will end up attracting your tribe any which ways.
Doesn't matter which medium you reach them from SO.
It everything in the end is certainly longevity.
It comes down to product and good product sells itself.
It might be slow in the start to gather momentum because people
have to it hear and understand and to touch and to fly and to.
But if you make good product, people want it and that's all
you have to do. And with the odd new businesses,
just great product. Like you say, be friendly, be
kind, be helpful and give the best service you can.
And guess what? People are going to love it.
Fingers crossed I am able to deliver on that.
Only time will tell, but at least I have the right
motivation and the pull for it. Yeah, what I was going to say is
that you pull yourself out of the rat race the moment you have
this mindset because otherwise it's a hamster review that will
never end. And the same goes for recording
these episodes, you know, like the the algorithm say is
released twice a week. The audience starts dropping if
I don't publish. And especially at the beginning
of the show, I spoke a little bit to the listeners and the
viewers that I was away and I couldn't publish as per schedule
for the past three weeks, three months or something.
But the bottom line is that had I did publish, the quality would
have been absolute shit because I was not in the right mindset
because I have to prepare for these episodes and do my own
research and prepare myself. Yet when I spoke with Russ or
with you or whatever episodes are published during this
period, they were very meaningful talks.
They were like very well received by the audit.
The retention rates were the highest that I've seen in quite
a while. As long as you've put your heart
and soul into it, the noise will fade away in the most beautiful
matter. Possible.
Absolutely, absolutely. There's nothing I can.
I just 100% agree with what you're saying and all all the
algorithms, everything there's. Unfortunately, the algorithm
doesn't take one thing into account.
It can't take into account the quality of the content or the
quality of the product. And at the end of the day, it is
the quality of the product in the user's hands or in the
user's ears that is relevant. And the algorithm is yet to be
able to understand that because that's a personal interaction
between you and that it's. So true, the human connect which
cannot be digitalised in one's in view of all the binaries, not
a algorithm speaks itself. Yet watch out.
I don't know where this is going, but from what we can tell
with with AI anything could be possible in the future.
I'll tell you one thing which gives me hope, Robbie, and this
is such a certain which gives me complete confidence that
humanity will win at the end of the day.
Generative intelligence is even more scarier, right, which is
coming on further in the future. That artificial is one thing,
but artificial generative intelligence is the whole
different thing. But I was speaking to someone
who said that until today, doctors have not been able to
map the area and brain where the pain is perceived, because
otherwise they would find a drug and kill that right?
Because pain goes all over the neurons, all over different
sides. And the medical science, no
matter how adverse it is, failing to decode it.
So that tells me that eventually nature has built its own
algorithms, which can never be, which can come.
You can try and mimic them. You can try and come close to
it. You can replace your mean, you
can replace your whatever you need in your body, but nothing
comes close to the nature or the miracle of it that we see.
It's all foreign games for big tech to go out and make
trillions or whatever paper or numbers in the bank account it
is, which are only going to mean so much because eventually even
that longevity guy is going to have to say goodbye to the body
and the soul is the only thing that survives.
And there's no way you can recreate Soul, even though you
can recreate a guard particle in the long tubes and try and
decode the making of the universe.
But Soul is pretty far away from human intelligence, and there's
nothing that scares me in that regard, I would say.
Yeah, I hope so. But the long and the short for
me is that generally is that it doesn't matter it, it doesn't
matter where we go, it doesn't matter what path we go on.
The only thing that matters is your existence within it, and
ultimately you are in control of that you.
We give up control and we relinquish control to the forces
that be. But this is how astounding
reality is. That and when you lose yourself
in your own meditation, things don't exist exterior to your own
meditation. So we allow all this news to
come into us and all affect us and AI and Oh my God, and
where's it all going to end? If you just ignore all that and
concentrate on what you're doing and put your telephone down,
nothing makes any, nothing matters.
I mean just as a matter at all. Does it matter if humanity is
going down a one way road to nowhere because of AI and our
capitalistic greed? It doesn't really matter at the
end of the day it'll all shake itself out and the universe will
continue. So yeah, it's only because we
get tangled in our self importance as the human species.
Oh my God the human species is under threat.
It's under threat. Yes, it always will be under
threat and it always has been under threat.
It's just we happen to be here now looking at it and thinking
that this is some pivotal point. The pivotal point could have
been 3000 years ago, it could be 3000 years in the future.
We don't know. It's just that we think this is
some particular point. We're manifested ourselves here
and now. So it's the important part, but
it's no more important or less important than any other part of
the human existence, prior or future.
You speak like a Yogi, man. Is that where you're heading
towards? No, no, all of it is trying to
just bring some form of rationale into the madness.
And if you bring some kind of rationale into it, then you get,
oh, you just try and realise that we're just such an
infinitesimal small point in time.
We're just, we're nothing in time.
It's just this tiny little mark on a line of God knows how long
Infinity as far as we know. And we're just at this
particular point. So why am I going to take this
point so seriously when there's a point just behind it and
there's a point in the in front of it?
It's just we get carried away in self importance because we're
having the experience now, but it's no more, no less important
than any other part of time. I want to drift off topic for a
bit for the sake of slime because I want to relate to it.
What's the most? Maybe spiritual is the right
word? What's the most spiritual
experience you've had while flying in your career?
Oof, sorry or a tough question, but it just.
Came No, no, it's good. It's good.
I was in the Himalayas with Bob Drury and Peter Brinkaby.
I was just close to switching the question to that that tell
me about your flying in Himalayas, but I had a feeling
that Himalayan Himalayas and spirituality are oh.
Yeah, they go together and we've been on the, we've been on our
feet for quite a few days. Four days of walking out of this
valley that unfortunately I'd pulled us into.
Oh. My God, we landed in the back.
Yeah, we landed in the middle of nowhere and when I say it was
really a long, it was a four day.
Was it 4 or 6 day? God, it was a four or six day
walk out. Anyway, it was super tough.
We got out and we ended up at this little village called Padam
which is up in Zankskar. Peter had bad ankles from an
accident that it had para lighting previously and so he
didn't want to come flying with us that night because of that
evening because he was needed to rest.
Myself and Bob took off and we went literally straight up to
07000 meters and yeah, it was huge.
Huge. You started from beer.
We've started from probably 4 1/2 thousand.
No, in beer building. No, we started.
Where did we start that one? We started in Manali.
Yeah, because one scar is further up.
Yeah, that scar is north. It's the other side of the,
yeah, other side of the past. And anyway, we took off.
It went straight up to 7000 and it was incredible landscape and
it was the first time ever that I just realised how totally and
utterly insignificant I was. And it's a beautiful thing to
have a moment in your life where you just are to recognise that
you are smaller than a leaf in the wind.
You just this landscape is so vast.
And so huge and so dauntingly threatening, but at the same
time beautiful. It's amazing.
Yeah. And then it was, my God, this is
really out there. This is you're nothing.
And yeah, it was that moment that, yeah, just changed.
It actually probably changed my life.
Now you're talking about bombing out and walking.
Yeah, no, no, sorry. This was after the bombing out,
just getting up so high so quickly in such a place and just
seeing the vastness. It was rough as well.
It was so you're getting old, rocked around and it's not, it
wasn't comfortable. It wasn't just, Oh my God, this
is beautiful. It was more like, whoa, this is
intense. And everything about it was
intense. And yes, it was that moment that
I just realised how totally insignificant I am.
And I use the word totally other words, totally insignificant I
am because I still am totally and utterly insignificant.
Really we're all just again, we fill ourselves with self
importance, which I have done because of the things that that
shape us, ego and all those things.
But the reality is that we're just all pretty insignificant.
It doesn't mean to say we don't have value, but there's just
massive insignificance to all our lives really.
They're all equally important, but none of them are important.
That's the most humblest statement, hands down, I've
heard in quite a while. And it's so nice that you're
aware of it. You go.
It's. Yeah, I can see that you've put
in the work within yourself. When you speak, I really don't
think I have. It's easy, Easier said I'm not.
Everything's a learning experience and we're learning
all the time. But we do have to really
recognise the fact that there's going to be thousands of souls
after US and there's been thousands of souls before us.
And how many of them are really relevant.
They've all been relevant in our evolution and they all will be
relevant in our evolution. But none of them, there are just
a few names in all of history or in in all of history at this
moment, that is recorded history at this moment that truly stand
out. And of those few names that
truly stand out, none of them are really relevant.
They're just, they just happened to be little islands that stand
out. But in another 1000 years, all
these names will be forgotten and we'll be dealing with a
different set of names that stand out because of the
evolution of consciousness and humanity within that
consciousness. Word golden words yeah I there
are 20 branches that I want to speak about like the 20 topics
that I want to branch out to, but somehow it just feels that
we have to save that for another day or be this is like.
Yeah, the The thing is, the the whole question of life is super
interesting. It's super interesting.
And you could argue that it's more interesting than anything
else if you actually get into thinking about it and trying to
understand yourself within it. The trouble is that we're always
trying to entertain ourselves. That's all we do.
Don't get me wrong, the podcast is another form of
entertainment, but I'm not belittling the podcast.
I'm not belittling anything. I'm just saying it's what we do.
We entertain ourselves and we find things to occupy our minds
with. Because if we stop and ask
ourselves the questions that are truly interesting and expansive,
it becomes difficult. Should we say?
Because then you've got to start dealing with the fact that, Oh
my God, I am irrelevant. Yeah, you are.
Yeah, for real. That is the truth.
Even though you're so. Full of your own self
importance, which I am, but the reality is it's just nothing
matters. It's like standing in that line
I was talking about earlier, when you're standing in the
queue and you want to be at the front and you've got other
things to do. Yeah.
And everybody else in front of you has got other things to do,
and everybody behind you has got other things to do.
And you think you're the important one because you have
to be on this next flight. You're just another person in
the whole thing who's totally irrelevant and it doesn't
matter. You've only created yourself
importance. OK, I'm going to tell my
audiences what I had for the show, like the structure.
And then they no, I think somehow we have ended up
covering it all. Robbie, I kid you right?
It was, it was five points that we spoke about.
And the first one was finding your passion or the calling.
The second one was finding the courage to go after the same.
And the third was making it sustainable financially and
emotionally. And that was followed by giving
back to the community. And then the last one was what
comes next after you have been there, done that.
And even though we might not have explicitly answered these
questions in a chronological way or something, but I seem like we
have given an overall idea more or less of how, yeah, the
thoughts around them at least. Feel free to let us know people,
how you felt, like how you found this.
For those of you who have stuck these two hours, because we do
have retention rates in the beginning of the show, but later
on, the patience of a human brain obviously goes down.
So for those of you who have stuck with us for so long, do
let us know in the comments because it's all about
connecting, right? And I would like to connect with
you guys rather than just having this as a one way conversation.
So looking forward to hearing your feelings, but yeah, I don't
know what can I be curious about next?
I've been very curious about the stories from back in the day
when you guys were exploring the Himalayas and B building or the
John Sylvester Times and Coracorums.
Man, these are like, to me, these are like fanboy moments
when I, when I think about them, I was like, these early pioneers
were going out and pushing the flight envelope of these brand
new machines. They were building themselves
and, you know, taking them in these crazy places and having
fun and finding the insignificance at the end of the
day and realizing all of that and what an emotional rush and a
roller coaster it must be. Yeah, I personally feel very
lucky and super privileged. Amazing people everywhere in my
story. Just inspirational people
everywhere. John Sylvester.
John Pendry, Russ, just the list, the list goes on.
There's so many amazing pilots, great people, and not all, not
just iconic names, but just doing a demo in Italy and
meeting passionate people who are just flying at the weekend
and excited to be a part of a, a demo weekend.
And you just, you have a great day with them and evening meal
and everyone's just buzzing from sharing the passion.
Yeah, it's the whole thing's just been incredible.
And it's, yeah, just an amazing story in my life.
And I'm sure there are equally as amazing stories in other
people's lives that have been running parallel to mine.
What's 1 commonality that you have seen in these people who
are able to chase their passion or maybe these names to that
which you mentioned, the amazing people?
What's 1 commonality that you've seen in most of them that makes
them stand out? Because I would like to do one
of one of those names at the end of the day when the curtains are
coming in to close. I would be like, yeah, if I can
look back and say that yes, I have done my own bit which was
appreciated by the ones who saw it through my eyes, then I think
I would have won at life basically.
Yeah, I would say that all of those people every or but again,
even those the those weekend pilots that you meet at those
demos and things, it's just people's passion.
It's very good to have true passion and you might not be
able to dedicated to it because you've got a family and you've
got a job that's five days a week and you only get the
weekend. So you might not have the same
potential to dedicated to the sport because you've got other
responsibilities. Most of those people that I talk
about have navigated and had prioritised their passion over
responsibility. Guilty as charged, yeah.
Totally me too. So maybe that's one trait, but
in general the thing that and the thing anyway that links all
pilots together, including hang gliders, sailplanes is, is
passion. You know, we, we're all
passionate people and we love this feeling that flight brings
us and this potential that flight brings us because it's
always an unknown potential. You take off, you don't really
know what's going to happen. Yes, you probably know, you
understand what's likely to happen, but you never know.
You can't see the air. So you're flying in a medium
that is invisible and you can only sense it through the
controls and through the environment around you.
But that's a beautiful thing to share, you know, and that that's
a very unique thing to share. And sometimes I think it's
something that we forget to recognise in our fellow pilots
is that everybody's out there just to to get to connect with
that special feeling that flight is.
So true. Yeah, well, I'm going to have to
stop and just say that let's call it a day because this is
the endless wonderful trail off the top that can keep on going
on that. But one thing I do promise to my
audience is that if you allow me, Robbie, I'd love to help you
that at later stage sometime when we find more topics
because, yeah, youthful, like an encyclopedia of end reality the
way you like it. And I don't know, man, I just
feel very relatable to you because, yes, we spoke about
Isle of Man, we spoke about the speed and all of those things.
And when you see somebody who has been there done that, I'm
like, shit, dude, I want to walk in those footsteps.
And of course, if I can walk an extra mile, it's even fun, at
least from the what what I see. I don't know what what else goes
behind the scenes, but from what I see is, yeah.
Thank you for showing us the way, Robbie.
Inspiration is an understatement.
You're much more than that. And what an honour to have these
two hours with you, man. I was, yeah.
About it, to be honest, I would just like to say though, thank
you very much for your kind words.
It's very kind of you to say those things.
But for as easy it is for me to have answers and insight for
your questions, I've made all the mistakes.
I've done many things badly, probably done more things badly
than have done well. And yes, it's because you're
asking these questions, you get the roses, but around the roses
there are also thorns. And I have those thorns and I've
made those mistakes. And it it doesn't, it's not all
just perfection or imperfection. It sorry, it definitely it's not
perfection. It's not all just the positive
side of things. There is plenty of negative
stuff as well. I have my own demons that I have
to battle like everybody does. But the most important thing
more than anything is that just get up, keep trying and keep
trying to make my life better. And hopefully everybody can do
the same thing. Just the whole gig is just about
trying to make your life better. Indeed, indeed.
And yeah, thank you for your honesty.
I think that is a good way to pause on this.
Excellent. Thank you very much.
Really appreciated it.